coreando consignas y portando la bandera
palestina cientos de personas asistieron
al funeral de alí harp un palestino de
28 años que murió tras ser apuñalado en
el corazón por un colono israelí en
cisjordania ocupada según la versión del
ministerio de sanidad del país árabe y
testigos
los colonos se reunieron a nuestro
alrededor y uno de ellos estaba un poco
lejos se acercó a nosotros y atacó al y
lo apuñaló con un cuchillo y huyó hacia
la policía israelí la policía del
ejército no hicieron nada incluso nos
impidieron acercarnos a él
sin embargo un portavoz de la policía
israelí dijo que no estaba claro quién
había asesinado al hombre y que estaban
investigando el incidente en el que no
se ha producido ninguna detención hasta
el momento un acontecimiento que ha sido
condenado por las autoridades palestinas
y por la comunidad internacional
conviene un apuñalamiento mortal de hoy
de un hombre palestino alejar al parecer
a manos de un colono israelí cerca de
salfit en cisjordania ocupada mi más
sentido pésame a su familia los autores
de la violencia deben rendir cuentas y
ser llevado rápidamente ante la justicia
el ataque se produjo en paralelo al
proceso de disolución del gobierno
israelí encabezado por naftalí bennett
la que en ese día dio un primer visto
bueno al proyecto de ley que dará paso a
elecciones generales las quintas en
menos de cuatro años de continuadas
crisis políticas y precipitadas
precisamente por la violencia mortal en
los territorios palestinos
la coalición perdió su mayoría
parlamentaria tras la deserción de edith
silman del partido de ultraderecha de
benet y el partido árabe islamista rahm
también congeló a finales de abril
durante tres semanas su participación en
el gobierno a raíz de los disturbios
violentos en la explanada de las
mezquitas de jerusalén durante el
ramadán